[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEGHAN MEHTA: Hey, Timothy,
we should go After Dark.
I want to go dancing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What?
MEGHAN MEHTA: I
want to go dancing!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What?
MEGHAN MEHTA: I
want to go dancing!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, let's do it!
[LIVE BAND PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I'm an enormous space nerd.
Do you have anything
space-themed?
- We have an awesome spaceship
tattoo that's really cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm in.
- I could do it right here.
Is that cool?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Sure.
- Ow.
- So I'm going to put
our unicorn on there.
MEGHAN MEHTA: We got a unicorn!
Oh, OK, so it says
"eats" over there,
and there's probably food.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh,
yeah, you hungry?
MEGHAN MEHTA: The cones of meat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's advice?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Yeah,
let's do this.
- What you do is
you ask a question.
MEGHAN MEHTA: What will I
have for lunch tomorrow?
So, like, I think I want a
salad, but I really want pizza.
Hi!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi.
Can I hug?
MEGHAN MEHTA: Oh.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, so good.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I'm
a little dusty up here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It won't come off!
MEGHAN MEHTA: I don't know,
this might be my new job.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Timothy, thank you so much
for hanging out with me
during my first I/O After Dark.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Are you kidding?
This was tons of fun.
I mean, this is what makes
it a developer festival.
[MUSIC PLAYING]